the kaiapoi east regeneration area of
approximately fifty three point five
hectares lies to the north of the
kaiapoi river and east of the town
center and is bounded to the south by
council-owned reserve land adjoining the
kaiapoi river traveling in a
northeasterly direction from the
supermarket building in charles street
the area has been identified as suitable
for business users which could include
vehicle parking or yard based activities
such as a plant nursery or car sales
yard to the southeast of Jones Street
bordered by charles street could be
suitable for parking including parking
for boat trailers a part of the area of
land stretching between charles street
and cass street would be suitable for a
caravan park managed by the new zealand
motor caravan association in the area
bounded by cass street in the south and
orem place in the north and following
around the line of Bracebridge street
and blackwell present up to the great
chris and reserve the land has been
identified as suitable for recreation
and an ecological link area uses could
include a food forest or community
gardens native planting or paths and
seating moving further east this has
been identified as suitable for district
sport and a recreation reserve there's
room for four full playing fields space
for junior or warm-up fields are
pavilion and changing rooms on-site
parking and also space for informal play
a further area suitable for recreation
and ecological linkage are joins the
grey crescent reserve running through to
filled with dr adjoining this to the
south the land has been ascertained as
suitable for an Ashes only cemetery area
turning in a southerly direction land to
the east of felt would drive has been
identified as suitable for rural use
excluding intensive farming this is also
the case for the land south of Cass
Street stretching down to the corcoran
reserve and ask hidden park further to
the east there's provision for proposed
stormwater management and immediately
east of that is a five metre strip which
could be a possible access area enabling
a walking and cycling link moving west
and back towards the supermarket in
Charles Street a land south of Cass
Street has been identified as suitable
for district sport or recreation and
could include a dog park or community
BMX track provision has also been made
for proposed stormwater management in
this area please note that there are
different roading options under
consideration in the kaiapoi east area
details of those can be found on the
council website or at redzone planned
indeed we'd like your comment on these
regeneration area proposals for full
details of all the options outlined in
let's plan order comment on the plan
visit the council website at waimakariri
govt tensed or red zone plantains it'd
or pick up a copy from any council
service center or library